you're on the Lifeboat okay these
pictures from the helmet camera of a
member of the Lifeboat crew show the
rescue of five exhausted migrants in the
channel hello
it gives you a sense of what the rnli
volunteers can face every time they take
to see hey this guy's unresponsive as
well now
all five who were picked up by a crew
from Dover including a 14 year old girl
were able to walk ashore
but the record number of Migrant
Crossings is putting unprecedented
demands on the rnli and divides some in
the Kent communities they pass through
would you think the answer is what would
you do David wimble was on the Lifeboat
crew at littlestone for 18 years
it's getting harder for the crews to
actually give up the time to go and do
this because most of them have full-time
jobs how difficult is
actually the rnli has always had the
Goodwill of local companies more and
more crew members are saying that
something's going to have to be done
sooner rather than later because they
they just can't it's not sustainable to
keep doing this
the rnli says it understands the demands
on its Cruise the whole concept of
volunteers waking up in the middle of
the night and leaving their families to
go to Sea to rescue strangers is a very
powerful one we are coming up with a
whole range of interventions which are
specifically aimed at looking after our
people improving our training and
improving our equipment
but it's not just the impact on Lifeboat
Crews which some find frustrating
these videos were shared with Sky News
by a Kent resident angry the charity
care for Calais which also operates in
France is allowed to meet the new
arrivals in Dungeness giving them things
like flip-flops food and water
we spoke to one of the charity workers
in the videos
what do you say to people who say that
your actions facilitate illegal
Crossings I think that that's a
misunderstanding of what these people
have been through yes we're friendly and
welcoming but nobody leaves their home
and makes such a dangerous journey to
get to the UK because somebody is
smiling and welcoming and offering some
dry clothes when they get to the beach
there are others who are hostile to the
small boats arriving but finding someone
to say so on camera isn't easy
Tina is a local resident in lid they
should send them to Rwanda
and them that can't go to Rwanda send
them back to France this is where
they've come from why why should the
British taxpayer have to pay to send
them anywhere Tina do you feel that
because you have these views people
judge you yeah of course yeah yeah I've
been called nasty names but it's like
water off the Ducks back I don't care
for some what really rankles is the
arrival on the Kent coast of economic
migrants though critics say for refugees
being selected to come to the UK through
legal routes is as random as getting
lucky in an amusement arcade
along the coast at dim church we met
butcher Andy Lawrence as a father of
three myself if I was in their position
would I do the same of course
meanwhile Smugglers continue to cash in
on migrants waiting for their chance to
cross the channel and finally make it to
Britain Lisa Holland Sky News Kent